[Music]
hey everybody
yeah it's monday it's your bald head
yeah i know i'm just so
i just gotta use like [ __ ] okay putting
like
wigs and hats on and stuff he's trying
to kill me guilt tripped me yeah i'm
putting all the [ __ ] out
already i'm not going on the
okay there you go there you go we saw a
[ __ ]
why we saw a [ __ ] movie the other day
that was yesterday last night
last night we watched it this is one of
the weirdest movies i've ever seen this
movie is like almost kind of like the
spirit
like the spiritual [ __ ] successor to
[ __ ] manos hands of fate
it wasn't that bad no it was just it was
weird it had like a really
so this came out in 1973 it's called
messiah of evil
yeah and shudder just added it i've
never seen it it's got a bunch of other
titles too like it was released under
the title
dead people it was released under the
title return of the living dead
like before that movie actually came out
and george romero tried to sue
but he wasn't six he didn't succeed
because they're like hey you don't have
rights over the phrase living dead this
one
it kind of gave me the same vibe as
early romero meets let's scare jessica
to death
meets death bed the bed that eats yeah
uh wasn't that bad well no i'm just
saying but it
it kind of had like a vibe that was kind
of similar to that yeah death bed the
bed that eats the title was the best
thing about it
um and also the part where the bed ate
the fried chicken
yeah that was also like that was high
hilarity right there
this movie the reason why it reminds me
of manos hands of fate is because
both movies are actually pretty good
ideas it's just that
they didn't quite have the budget to um
to execute
that story this one
they had more of a budget it's executed
a lot better than mano's hands of fate
but it is [ __ ] strange it's it's a
surreal very strange movie
it's a very good idea um it could have
been
you could reshoot this movie uh you know
with modern technology and
keep most of the story the same and it
would work
it it does it kind of works the way it
is
yeah because some of the shots and stuff
were like pretty creepy so i think it's
and it doesn't i mean it has a story
but a lot of it is kind of left to the
imagination
i guess which like i said it's kind of
just let's scare jessica to death
is almost like the same exact vibe as
this
the the movie begins and ends with a ma
with a female
doing a monologue you're not really
she's evidently in an insane asylum
telling you this story
yeah what happened to her you're not
sure
if the story really happened or not
and the story is what seems to be kind
of like a zombie outbreak
but there's more to it than that yeah
they're not really zombies though
no i mean they're kind of i don't know
we'll get in it's kind of like something
out of them
that uh john carpenter flick where
uh like a demon shows up what was the
name
what was the one where there's a demon
doing all this different [ __ ] and
it's like one of carpenter's worst
movies which one prince of darkness
prince of darkness it kind of reminds me
of prince of darkness
you're not really sure what's going on
some dude comes out of the hills back in
the 1800s and starts spreading this
religion that somehow causes people to
become cannibals
and they're still out there and it it
it's
it's quite convoluted for me it was i
was losing track of it but it was kind
of cool to watch
yeah it's a really it has like a really
high rating on shutter it has five
skulls
and a lot of the other reviews there's
not a [ __ ] ton of other reviews of this
but some other horror channels have
reviewed it and most of them like seem
to really dig it they said now you
really have to be in the mood to watch
it
yeah 70s because it's 70s as [ __ ] and
it's like
it's one of those really surreal like
dreamlike
kind of things where it's like you're
not entirely sure what's going on
but there's but there's some really
really nice shots in it and like some of
the sequences are really cool
you just have to kind of like just let
it there's characters in washington
what it is there's one hot 70s chick she
looks like a model
walking around she's got a nice wreck
and then there's this dude with his two
girlfriends
yeah and he and he's he's like a
pathological liar i guess
about how rich he is and he's got one
girl and
one girlfriend has the mind of a child
because he's what he said
he called her a mind of a child she's
like a dingbat and then the other
girlfriend
is a little more sophisticated they pick
on her all kinds of weird [ __ ] happens
then they then the girls try to to screw
the hot girl and
or at least try to talk her into it it
didn't work not that i remember that
never did work did it
no i don't think yeah it didn't work
it's it it's it's [ __ ]
this is
like i said it reminds me very very
strongly of let's scare jessica it's
also kind of like a an
all all-star
hollywood z-lister cast
in other words you'll you recognize a
lot of these people they're kind of like
the z-listers from hollywood well i mean
alicia cook jr who was in [ __ ]
everything he was in household haunted
hill yeah i'm like [ __ ] he's in
everything
different levels some of them are
c-listers you know but a lot of brazil
they got the dude who played leon from
[ __ ] uh uh
blade runner he he's just in it for a
few seconds
he's like one of the extras well the
girl that plays or the woman that plays
the lead
marianna hill she was in a bunch of like
tv back then like manics and [ __ ] like
that
so it's like all these people are kind
of recognizable yeah one of the one of
the bums that's in there the bum that's
in there he's he's like
he was like in a bunch of twilight zones
and yeah that's a that's alicia cook
james that is his name okay yeah he's
like your standard bum character
yeah he's in it yeah he was on a fox
tunnel um just
it's a trip man so i'm gonna try okay so
fun fact
the uh the directors of this are
uh willard hoyk i think is how you
pronounce it and gloria katz it's
husband and wife
uh fun fact i think i already said that
they work a lot with george lucas
they were actually the two that wrote
the original screenplays for american
graffiti
and indiana jones the temple of doom and
these two
might have or at least uh willard hike
might have done
a rewrite on the original script of star
wars
uh so he might have had his hand in that
mix too and they would later go on to
direct
howard the duck which i don't care if
people say howard the duck is a bad
movie i
really have a lot of affection for
howard the duck it's a weird [ __ ] movie
too
but let me see okay so let me see if i
can describe
this movie it in a way conceptually it
seemed like it was really ahead of its
time
it has a lovecrafty type of [ __ ] going
on too yeah and i think that was
deliberate
yeah well it's kind of like what i was
saying it kind of reminded me of like
one of george romero's takes on [ __ ]
lovecraft stuff
that's yeah it's kind of it's not this
is like early romero like martin
type or what was that weird one that he
did about the witch late
the the coven of witches i watched that
one not too long ago and shut her too
that was
also a weird ass movie and this was like
the early 70s were
a weird time it's in there saying that
my hair is redefining god
yeah i'm redefining god and then
nick oh my god
that's somebody says uh the the quote
she's got a nice rack is that on the
blu-ray cover it's gonna be it ought to
be
yeah you got a nice wreck it's just it's
the season of the witch thank you
that's the name of that movie yeah yeah
so you know it's
there's eye candy in it there's [ __ ]
good
there's interesting locations that kind
of take you back to the 70s if you're
around during that time
the way mobile gas stations looked um
i feel like mobile may be paid for some
product placement
i think there might have some product
because there's some significant [ __ ]
that happens at like a bubble gas
station and they show the sign and [ __ ]
too
then they go inside of theaters and they
and you actually can see the candy
rack inside the theater and you go like
oh man that's the old the old milk dud
box
yeah and the old [ __ ] uh nestle
crunch bars
yeah the way the old rappers looked and
everything i remember when i was a kid
i did honeys they had bit of honeys in
there you know what it's like i never
liked those when i was a kid but i kind
of developed a taste for it when i got
older
for some reason i was when i was a kid i
thought they were gross but i don't know
when i got older i liked them yeah
but so i'm going to try and explain what
goes on in this movie and i'm not
entirely sure
so i'm just going to yeah right now it's
super bizarre
so so at the so it's bookended by like
you said this narration
by the main character who is in an
asylum so we're not entirely sure if all
the [ __ ] that happened
in between the the sandwich of her
narration
um is like just her imagination or
i kind of think it's not but you know
whatever so
you have that and then she's playing
this woman
her name is arletti which is weird i was
like
i never heard anybody named that you
said maybe there is i don't know
so she's named that and she says that
she's been getting letters from her dad
and her dad is like this weird like
artist type dude
and he left her and the mom and went
to this kind of seaside town
called i thought it was called point
dune
but i the wikipedia page says point doom
with an
m like d-u-m-e yeah so i don't know
which one it was i didn't i didn't have
the uh
closed captioning on so i didn't really
know probably so
yeah so she's like so her dad starts
like writing her these weird letters and
like they get weirder and weirder and
then they start like coming less and
less and she starts getting worried
about him so she decides to go to this
remote like seaside town
and see what the hell there you go yeah
oh my gosh
just keep going i know you know i can't
do that i have a resistance you know i
can't do that you gotta have a
resistance
it's like he puts on the wig and then
he's he sits there like that like i'm
supposed to react and then i really i do
react and then
but yeah so it didn't happen okay i'm
gonna pretend it didn't happen
so she goes to this town and she goes in
the
in her dad's house which is this big i
mean he's got these weird-ass like
paintings like he's painted all over the
walls
like he painted remember we thought it
was inside a mall for a second because
there's like these kind of like
there's trump paintings of uh escalators
and like there's all these like creepy
looking people like on the walls
there's a very very 70s uh platform bed
that's like hanging from chains
in the middle of the which i thought was
very nice and uh so there's that
but then she gets to the house and
nobody is there like her dad isn't there
and all the towns people are like super
weird because i think even before she
gets into town and when she stops at the
mobile station
remember there's that like super creepy
dude that's like standing there
yeah he's they've got this dude that
shows up and he's he's like in it a lot
he
he actually does a great job man with
this i think that guy was not an actor
no no he just he was the torgo of the
[ __ ] movie that's that's why i was
yeah he's the target
yeah he's the targo of the movie
he takes care of the place yeah he's an
alberto black dude
yeah and he's like tall he's like
[ __ ] huge he's like six foot eight or
some [ __ ]
yeah and he and his line delivery and
the [ __ ] that he does this [ __ ] trip
he's eating [ __ ] mice and chewing on
what one
and he's the torgo of he's collecting
bodies and living people and
driving them places and you just got to
see it man
and he's this is a weird house yeah he's
now basically you know right here for
the festival or
it's some kind of ritual you're here for
the rest of the waiting is the waiting
oh yeah
and he's like she's like no and he's
like oh but he's definitely the torgo of
the movie if you've seen [ __ ] hands
of fate
yeah man hands hands of faith yeah hands
the hands
hands hands of faith
but yeah so so she gets there and then
she ends up meeting
oh okay so i i was like well how does
she meet these like weird swinger people
but she ends up going to the
ruffle it's a yeah that's wrong that's
what it is i hate that word
like like i understand where it came
from but i was like come on you can come
up with a better neologism than that
but um yeah so she goes to the art
gallery
thinking that because her dad's an
artist and he supposedly sold some of
his paintings there that these people
know where the [ __ ] he went
they pretend like they don't know who he
is or that
he never came there and they didn't sell
the paintings and it's just like this
whole weird thing
and everyone's super standoffish and she
just kind of wanders around looking
[ __ ] lost and everything
and then she ends up meeting this dude
whose name is tom but with an
h tom no it's t-h-o-m
sorry that was an mst joke so anyway um
and he has two
girlfriends and he says he's from
portugal and he's a duke or some [ __ ] i
don't know he's like blowing [ __ ] out of
that he's lying
and uh they well they're like
interviewing elisha cook jr's bomb like
drunken bomb character
in this hotel room because tom says he's
interested in legends
and so the bomb is telling them about
this legend about this town that every
hundred years there's like a blood moon
and then there's a dark stranger that
comes
and all the towns people like wait out
on the beach with like bonfires and
they're waiting for this dark stranger
to come back and then
they all turn into something so at first
because at first when we were first
watching it because a couple of people
that get killed off screen
uh they said oh they look like they were
chewed up by dogs and there's like
um i think she hears like something in
the background and she's like oh that
didn't really sound like dogs
so at first time i was like is this
werewolves this is werewolves oh yeah
and i'm just like i don't know if it is
werewolves though it's like i couldn't
really
try to go there messiah of evil doesn't
really sound like a werewolf movie
yeah but the title was made after the
movie was done i'm trying
but it to up not it's not werewolves i
think they i think they
considered it possibly become being a
werewolf movie at one
one time at one point i kind of think
that the movie was rewritten
during the time i kind of feel like they
wanted to have a monster that wasn't
real
identifiable in the sense that because
they ended up with
well yeah that's what i mean so they
kind of wanted to keep the monster
because it's not even really a monster
it's just this weird it's like a cult
of death of cult of people that have
come back from the dead i guess
yeah it's like they call them undead but
they're not dead though they don't die
it's like it's almost like a disease
yeah but it turns you into a cannibal
and then like at the end when they talk
about the dark stranger that came there
like a hundred years ago
and he said that he had been in the
donner party and then he ate people the
donner party in that but as i was like
so easy like a when to go
so maybe he's turning people into
wendigos i don't know i don't know i was
i was like
the wind to go concept i don't think
maybe i'm thinking too much about it
well well they kind of look like
vampires too like their eyes start to
bleed
and they don't feel pain anymore and
they start like their body temperature
goes way down
and then because remember there's that
great scene where one of the one of the
thrupple
yeah goes into a ralph's supermarket and
there's nobody in there it's like the
middle of the night but it's still open
and she goes in there
and then she goes it doesn't seem like
anybody's in there but then when she
goes to the back like where the meat
section is like all the towns people are
in there just like eating raw meat out
of the [ __ ]
uh out of the butcher case and it's just
like that's actually a really good scene
i liked that
uh that a lot but so i don't know and i
mean that scene
and the scene where the other girl goes
to the movies
and she goes to the movie theater and
there's like nobody in there except like
a couple people
and then as she sits there like watching
the trailer or whatever trailers
like people like creepy towns people
start coming in and like sitting all
around like behind her and stuff and she
doesn't really realize what's going on
and then she turns around she's like oh
[ __ ] you know what i mean and then
and then basically they eat her i mean
they ate they don't show that
but that's what the implication is like
everybody jumps on her and like starts
eating her so they're like
they're not dead so they're not
zombies but they're yeah but they're
like it's almost like a disease like a
vampire type of thing but then it makes
them cannibals so that's why i thought
it was kind of like a maybe like a
wendigo situation
but then the whole thing about the dark
stranger returning when there's a blood
moon and like everybody waiting by the
ocean
and i think they even say at the end
that like the chems comes from the ocean
so i was like that's kind of love crafty
yeah that's kind of where i got
underneath the water
yeah and uh then she then she uh i guess
wakes up and she's in the mental asylum
and she says they somehow saved her and
took her to the
and then then you're like man that [ __ ]
was hallucinating the whole thing that
didn't happen
i thought though i don't know that they
let her go because
they wanted her to like tell the world
about it because they wanted
that that was the whole thing they had
come to like to this town and it was
like spreading because everybody in the
town
was getting it like it was hard to tell
i mean
yeah it's hard to tell it's really hard
to describe this movie if you haven't
seen it yeah
a better version of this would have been
dead and buried all right it was similar
yeah oh yeah now that you say no no you
bring that up but um
but this is still pretty good for what
it is
you just got to trip out you have to be
in the 70s kind of mood
yeah yeah but you know mr roboto says so
30 days of night
it is like some i did see another review
that kind of compared like
thematically but otherwise it's nothing
the same no they're not
really they're not vampires i mean
they're not
they look pale and like i said their
eyes bleed and stuff but they don't die
they're not undead
really they're just it's like they get a
disease and it makes them cannibals
the tone is simple and you can you have
to burn them you can't like
you can't just stab them because they'll
get back up the tone is kind of similar
to what i remember
rabbit being kind of like that yeah
yeah not as competent but i think rabbit
had a better budget
and it was a little more coherent this
could this could use a streamlined edit
but there i don't know how much movie
would be left if you did that
it's 70s it's all over the place it's
like an art film
yeah i do kind of feel like during the
70s there were a lot of these
and i think um the wikipedia page talked
a little bit about you know the
horror writer kim newman and he writes a
lot about
horror and he was saying that you know
in the 70s probably between night of the
living dead
and you know like the early 80s when
slashers and stuff like that started
taking over
there was this kind of he calls it the
american nightmare
where it's just like there there was a
lot of opportunity for these kind of
like weird-ass
idiosyncratic like filmmakers to make
these cheap ass movies
that would get released by like major
studios and because i think actually
this movie was picked up i think by 20th
century fox i want to say or something
like that
um unless i'm totally remembering that
wrong but
so so i feel like there's there was this
time period where everybody's making
this weird as [ __ ] cuz even a lot of
like george romero's early
movies were super weird like i said like
season of the witch and even the crazies
was a little bit weird
and uh you know martin and so it was
just kind of like
in the what was going on at the time
like i don't know if it was the drugs or
if everybody was just just seeing what
they could do so a lot of movies that
came out around this time period
have this really surreal like
nightmarish
kind of where it's like they they're not
really all that plot-centric you can't
really
like everybody in this movie i don't
know what their deal is
you know what i'm saying like like why
the the fake portuguese count with the
two girlfriends like where did
like was he supposed to be the dark
stranger like was that what they were
implying like i didn't really get
that um you know the the woman who came
to see her dad it's like what was her
deal like they're all just ways of
getting
she was just like walking around like
she was on quaaludes all the time it's
just like it's just very very strange
it's a very strange movie
it's just a way of getting your friends
into the movies i think i guess
all right you're reading into it too
much
that's who was involved and that's who
is in the movie so they just made
characters for them
it it's just it was movies from another
time
there was before cable there were a lot
more theaters
it was it was a lot more theater culture
was a lot more prevalent people went to
movies a lot more often because tv
really sucked
all right um the technology sucked there
wasn't much
in terms of there was only a couple
channels you know
you might live in a place where there's
only like two or three television
channels and you might only be able to
get two of them really well the other
one you have to adjust the damn rabbit
ears and i [ __ ] that up
too much trouble so there were a lot of
theaters
and um so there wasn't any kind of
there wasn't a lack of theater space or
time you know i mean
nowadays if you have a theater that
[ __ ] crammed full of [ __ ]
expensive movies that some studio made
and they want to return they want to
make money on that thing
uh well you know maybe not in the past
couple years is this amc's falling apart
but
that was how that business worked
well back then in this particular time
you could take a small movie that
didn't cost much to make that a studio
bought for cheap and they still had
space to put it up space and time to put
it
on with theater onto a screen and
hopefully make some money off of it
did they make much money probably not
because they didn't continue it
i feel like this was kind of more a
drive-in type of thing yeah those two
those they had those and um honestly
until
i think it got like a kind of a nice
special edition recently
but prior to that really the only way
you could see this movie
was on one of those remember you buy
those big like dvd packs of like 50
drive-in classics and they were all like
in the public domain so like
living dead and [ __ ] was on there so
this usually turned up on those
kind of kind of things you have to
understand that that time you know what
i mean jenny and i caught the tail end
of it
uh a driving a drive-in
movie theater was really just an
underage love hotel
after all the high school students
[ __ ] took the car to parks they could
get cracking so the [ __ ] car is
bouncing in the back let's go to the
back
yeah you could hear them back there yeah
and it was wilder than you think because
not only were you and the girlfriend in
the back seat your boy and his girl were
in the front seat
so it was group sex too that sucks
giving him the front seat because
he might trade up so everybody had to
know each other real well
you might have had one car like get that
foot out of my face so
hey tom tom tom look oh yeah
[Laughter]
you just did funny [ __ ] you know it was
like you didn't have a good sense of
humor back then
that's true yeah there's another time so
maybe well maybe
that's why like a lot of these weird-ass
movies got made because people weren't
really watching them next
there you go it was filler
a lot of it you know they had time and
space for that
it would be the equivalent of like a
[ __ ]
youtube channel you know what i mean you
needed youtube channels but they were
making money on them
yeah you know what i mean so there was
no youtube
but you had movies like this and you
could put that up in the drive-in
and give the kids an excuse to come into
the [ __ ] drive-in
because they weren't watching the movie
per se yeah
every now and then you kind of look i'm
good that's kind of yeah in between
drinking and smoking cigarettes and
getting head or whatever get ahead
depending on what your position was
but the uh you might go up and look at
it and goof on the movie
you know and then look at the other cars
and try to figure out you know it's like
you know where's jason there he is and
you're talking to talk about
who's he's with and that kind of you
just see like a naked butt like where's
there
where's there where's there where is
there who's he in there oh he's with
he's with lisa
all right just sit like that you know
because
yeah yeah it's just whatever and you
know and it might be
the couples might be different you know
because we you know
we had a dating culture back then you
didn't everybody dated
dayton wasn't the same as going steady
so everybody was switching up
we're going to try different ones try
them out man
take them on a test drive the girls are
doing the same thing
the girls are doing the same thing it
was
nothing personal you go you take her out
one weekend and then your boat your
buddy take her out the next weekend and
then you just flip-flop
uh you know i was like yeah but that's
the way the culture was we didn't really
even get jealous
granthar's probably in the conversation
he'd probably back me up on that i went
to high school with him he knows exactly
what i'm talking about
we didn't get jealous yeah i wonder i
don't think i've seen it
right out there you had to be lame to
get jealous back then
people that didn't get dates got well as
i said i think that's kind of where
this movie was coming from too because
and this is very much like where it
reminded me of uh let's scare jessica to
death which we did a review of like a
long time ago
because that was a similar thing where
thank you no need for me to get the
donations rolling and shows are so
entertaining
yeah yeah yeah switching up and you like
laughing yeah
um just sound like it is yeah or like it
was
uh because in that movie remember like
it was the
the husband and wife and then they move
to this weird house and then like they
have all these like weird hippies moving
and they're all
and she's all trying to make moves on
the husband and the wife
yeah so it's just so i feel like there
was all this kind of like 70s woo free
love kind of [ __ ] yeah
and that's kind of what was going on in
this because they don't really give an
explanation as to who this tom person is
or
you know why he has these two chicks
with him and what they're even doing
there like what are they even doing in
this town
i mean you're kind of led to believe
that they came there because
like i said tom was interested in
legends and he just heard about like the
whole blood moon thing going on
and so he's there like interviewing
people but then they don't leave
and then even like when bad [ __ ] starts
to happen
and i don't know so i've seen a couple
people think that
maybe he's supposed to be the
incarnation of the dark stranger
but like coming back because it's time
for him to come back but i don't think
that really scans because
he well they don't really show him like
he dies at the end but he's because they
go out in the ocean and then like he's
suddenly just not there anymore
so maybe he was the dark stranger all
along i don't know if that was what they
were going for i think that maybe they
should have set that up a little bit
better
and the two girlfriends he brought with
him both get eaten by the townspeople
so i don't know i don't get it but
but like i said it's one of those movies
where just you know
just drop some acid and like just watch
it
and don't worry about it too much yeah
because it's just like the imagery is
weird
and it's just it doesn't make a whole
lot of sense like it kind of has a story
but
not really like not anything you need to
concern yourself
with over much um i think later like the
screenwriters came out and like
talked about how they kind of disavowed
this movie because they're just like oh
my god it was like so bad
but i do i kind of feel like after at
times it was re-released in the 80s like
under a different title like i said it
was called dead people
but it kind of like went away like it
was kind of like went under the radar
and like i said the only place you could
get it was some of those like cheap ass
dvd packs with like 50 movies on them it
has a choppy edit
yeah all right that's why they don't
like it
some of the recording of the audio track
the audio recordings are kind of rough
voiceover is pretty rough the way it was
done
um it's not a very smooth movie
but it kind of adds to this kind of
[ __ ]
kind of illicit underground feel to it
it feels like an art film
it oh it definitely does it definitely
does and it's just
70s as [ __ ] it's just kind of like
kind of like an upscale version of manos
hands of fate
yeah which i could watch that movie that
movie's [ __ ] weird man
well i i mean i'm really glad that sort
of mystery science theater brought
manos back into the public consciousness
because that movie
is just so strange
it's like it's bad but it's just like
it's so entertaining and like hypnotic
because it's so strange and this one has
that same kind of quality too
yeah like i said it's almost kind of
like i and i want to say it was a little
bit like deathbed the bed that eats too
but this is like a lot better than that
one because
that movie was like boring as [ __ ] yeah
that was just like hey let's go sleep on
this bed in this random
the place in the forest you got to give
it that
yeah it's definitely not boring neither
was manos manos wasn't boring either
because yeah because you're like the
whole time you're like what the [ __ ] am
i watching yeah
a lot of the problems with manos and i
think are are what made it interesting
and the problem really centered around
the fact that they had a camera
that didn't have any sound recording
ability and it could only record about
five seconds at a time i think it was 30
seconds 30 seconds i think it was 30
seconds
every cut yeah third that's around five
seconds
yeah that would be everything
was rough and i think they i think they
[ __ ] shot the thing in camera if you
ask me
oh i'm sure they did yeah real rough
well the guy that made it was not a
filmmaker
it was just like a hobby yeah and and
um so then i think almost everything was
done in one take
wouldn't surprise me and um
then they later added voice over to it
they dubbed it which made it even more
shitty looking but it ended up being
real creepy
when it was done yeah it definitely has
that vibe to it doesn't it
yeah and they had weird characters in
there and towards the end there's this
whole [ __ ]
coven of witches [ __ ] try um
worshiping this cult leader and they're
trying to bring the old cult leader back
from the dead if i remember
correctly weren't they they're bringing
back to life
or something something like it wasn't
super clear
and nobody's an actor or actress in this
movie yeah i think it was like all the
dude's friends
yeah and at the end the coven of which
is
they're kind of not scandily it's not
that they're scandily clad they're just
wearing these kind of [ __ ]
loose-fitting robes that are real kind
of sheer
and it you think porn's gonna break out
and it's
and they're actually pretty cute most of
them so you're like what the hell is
going on there they were they were
wrestling and i think
i think some of them haven't been each
other yeah and i think some of you one
of them even killed another one
if i remember correct i think they
slapped torgo to death yeah that's right
they did all kinds of
[ __ ] you're like what the [ __ ] is this
movie about
but not yet i kind of love it though
yeah so this one kind of i'm kind of
it it's like a high an upscale version
of mano's hands of fate i'll put it at
that level
yeah it's for sure as weird as that yeah
it's as weird as that but
it's as if you actually knew how to make
a movie yeah and is and
if you had equipment and actual like
actors
and actually that had
one of the weirdest things too about
manos is that so
so a lot of the shots like i said
because the camera couldn't record sync
sound
um so what he would do is like if two
characters are having a conversation he
would focus on the one that wasn't
talking
yeah and so then there would be like the
other person would be talking from like
off camera yeah
and it was like really unsettling yeah
yeah it's very unsettling
actually you know if you haven't seen
this movie see it but i also want to
plug manos [ __ ] see manos hands of
fate
too i mean that [ __ ] there the riff
tracks live
version of it is a delight yeah and i
think that's actually on to be
yeah for free like you can watch it i
think it's on tv or maybe it's on pluto
yeah but i think that's all i can say
about this movie yeah it's they like i
said they just added it on shutter not
too long ago and i said oh that sounds
creepy and i love like [ __ ] 70s [ __ ]
and um i'm actually so we watched it
last night i'm just like this is one of
the weirdest [ __ ] movies i've ever
seen
it's so [ __ ] weird but it's like i
don't know you
you really have to kind of be in the
mood for it because like i said it's one
of those
just it's almost like watching a dream
like someone's dream and it doesn't make
a lot of sense but
i don't know there's something kind of
compelling about it nonetheless
yeah and if anybody else watches it like
let me know like are those people
wendigos i kind of thought they were
maybe winning graphics is in there
grandpa's i was just talking about you
man
talking about that damn [ __ ] driving
over there trenton
we used to go to that [ __ ] was the
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was just the de facto
love motel for [ __ ] all the underage
high school kids
we'd be up in there [ __ ] seeing whose
car was there
because we knew who they were with see
the cars [ __ ] in the bounce in the
bag bouncing
bouncing me and steve would be up there
[ __ ] with our dates and [ __ ] going
yeah he's giving it to her good look at
that [ __ ] car
that's [ __ ] those because windows are
all steamed up with
that [ __ ] that's [ __ ] funny it was
yeah actually gramster said why don't
you two make a horror movie you know
it's goth night at eye bar then a bunch
of mundanes show up and out come the
machetes
if i actually if i was gonna make a
horror movie i would not make a slasher
no i would make like more of an arty
party
like scary very difficult to make a
movie the right way
you have to have a good script and you
have to understand your limitations
and um the best thing to do would be
make something [ __ ]
absolutely insane like velocipaster
that might be the way to go it's just
because like i said if you're if you
have those limitations
in um you know and like i said we were
talking about manos it's like i really i
think the idea for manos was like
actually a really good creepy idea
um it's just he didn't really have the
the you know the expertise or the
equipment or the money
to pull it off the way he wanted but it
was still a good idea it was a good
concept
and i feel like if you don't have
the equipment and it's just going to be
like look cheap
then just lean into it because if you
try to make a serious movie and you
don't really know what you're doing
you're just gonna like shoot yourself in
the dick he grabs in there grabs in
there laughing is the fort
george drive-in that's right is that
that's just still there
there's very few drive-ins yeah so they
kind of had a little bit of a resurgence
i feel like but
you could probably really update one
with some kind of digital projector
well yeah i think some of them have and
you could change those speakers see
those speakers had to be
shitty they were in iron boxes yeah that
were like almost changed to the [ __ ]
so people wouldn't say something no
people forget
to take them out and drive away like
that
but no you gotta also gotta remember
that they were out there in the [ __ ]
sub-zero [ __ ] weather
all the time and being rained on all the
time they had to be bulletproof
so they were it was basically a squawk
box
yeah you wouldn't need that nowadays
though because you could stream it
through wireless devices now
well i thought back in the old days even
when i was a kid i thought that there
was like a local they they did it like
through a local radio station so you
could tune in like on your radio
yeah i mean right i thought they some of
them did that yeah because i thought the
one we went
only only it was just like yeah just
right just right around there so you
sometimes it'd be like hard to find it
like on the band or whatever but i
remember i remember like ones that had
that
box outside but i mostly remember tuning
in on the radio on the car radio that's
how you do it today
yeah it doesn't make much sense but
that's all it's all it would be good for
is basically a love motel
well and i feel like now like well just
like movie theaters in general if you're
gonna do it you have to have like some
kind of theme
you know what i mean you'd have to have
like events it would have to be like an
event like everybody to go
yeah like you know what i mean like you
know how they have like one of the more
famous ones
is um you know every now and then
they'll so like every year they'll show
jaws
but they show it like there's a pool and
you like watch it
while you're in the water like in an
inner tube you know what i mean
graham says no man it's long gone it's
now a major big box grocery
yeah all right uh he said it still
sounded like crap at the radio at fort
george though too
yeah or they started sounding like crap
where we live we used to go to the um
i think it was just called the nova road
drive-in it was just on the corner nova
road and hand avenue
and i was uh it's been gone a long time
but um
i was in daytona not too long ago
because i went through daytona going up
to saint augustine
and um there's like a big yeah i think
it's a wawa is there now
or something like that and maybe like a
caterpillar rental place or some [ __ ]
they shouldn't have gotten rid of them i
mean they did
they did serve a [ __ ] uh important
function in society and that was to keep
the kids from [ __ ]
in in lovers lanes and getting their
[ __ ] killed by the damn [ __ ]
nightstalker by the phantom killer
yeah because sometimes we'd have to
[ __ ] go out and go hide somewhere
you know [ __ ] down by the river you
know there'd be cars parked out all the
cops knew what was going on
or behind the church that's where a lot
of that's where a lot of people
went all the cops the church had a big
parking lot you couldn't see it like
all the cops knew because they'd [ __ ]
drive by and then they wouldn't stop
they knew what's going on back there
well it's like if they stopped and like
did that every time they wouldn't do
anything else you know what i mean so
it's just kind of like what
it is yeah well you know
it's better that your kids you know
they're going to the drive and they're
contained in that area right there you
know what it's all about let's keep
those kids contained they're keeping
them contained
and they're keeping [ __ ] perverts
from out of there or whatever you know
well actually
just just kid perverts in there yeah
kids give me perverts all your [ __ ]
favorites yeah
like a right it's funny but you know
there weren't any adults in there
yeah well we say kids you know we didn't
think of ourselves as kids back then you
know [ __ ]
when you're in high school
yeah because you know you're only a
couple years away from graduating
and getting the [ __ ] out on your own you
know yeah louis says there's still some
drive-ins in uh
socal haven't been to one in years yeah
i think there's still some
um but you know they they tend to do
you know a special event i guess more
special event type stuff
yeah i think it'd be fun although if it
you know if they had him in florida i
think i'd rather go in the [ __ ]
winter time i'm not going to a [ __ ]
driving
yeah you'd have to leave the air
conditioner running yeah like the whole
time
yeah it's like a whole two-hour movie
last i remember going when i was a kid
because they used to do like
all night they'd do like five or six
movies
like one after the other and it was
always like a wildly
they didn't even like have themes or
anything it's like let's show texas
chainsaw massacre too
and license to drive yeah graham's going
i wonder how many teenage boys got their
first hand job at fort george
probably almost as many stars in the
night yeah
yeah first time you're grabbing teddies
and [ __ ]
huh get that get that off there that's
back when back when bra was [ __ ] you
know [ __ ] in the back here i could
get it in the back
well they still do in the back yeah no
then
someone no then later on he started
doing them in the front yeah but i had
some
in the front in high school yeah and
easy it was but i didn't love it because
sometimes
if you just went like that too quick it
would go doink yeah and then you'd be
like
me and then you'd have to like reach
under your shirt and like redo it in the
middle of class i had that happen lots
and lots of times yeah if i can
grab those i'd be down to driving with
cheryl remember her
yeah she was like stacked [ __ ] man that
girl was like like a double e
cute and her boobs were also contained
within the drive-in yeah she had a good
hourglass figure and everything
that's red hair yeah tom's around
remembers her yep he'll remember he
remembers the last name and everything
yep
nope we're calling her out calling her
out
starts with an r oh well hopefully she
doesn't watch this channel
she's good i'm friends with i'm friends
with her still okay facebook yeah
she's cool she's a nurse she's a nurse
now oh okay that's cool
all right do we have anything else uh
you want to say about this weird ass
movie
nah that's just a sigh of evil like i
said if you're into 70s surrealism if
you like to let scare jessica to death
you'd probably this would probably be
right up your alley yeah and it's on
shutter
you can maybe watch it elsewhere but
shutter just added it not too long ago
we got intrigued
yes so you know like i said drop some
ass and watch the [ __ ] yeah it's weird
as hell
all right so uh we will be back tomorrow
we've actually
we're going out tonight yeah so we've
already watched the movie that we're
gonna talk about tomorrow which is
actually a brand new one
so uh i'm gonna tell you what it is
though just because i'm being
coy like that so yeah thanks everybody
for hanging out with us today
and we will talk to you guys again
tomorrow afternoon bye